what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i have my little sister amelia as
a guest on the channel
hi she is super excited to be here i
swear i am not
forcing her before i start do not forget
to subscribe to the channel and bring
that notification
bell so today we're going to be reacting
to top 21 tick tock
mgtow truths why men stopped dating
so this will be an interesting
conversation because amelia's 10 years
younger than me so
it's like one generation a different
generation it'll be interesting to see
if she thinks this stuff is true or
false
okay hey babe
would you still love me if i was fat
yeah of course
but mom you are fat
i love hearing about guys bad dates
they'll be like oh
she didn't offer to split the bill so
right when coach started i had a
girl that i was talking to come on over
and
hang out with me right but she came over
completely drunk
she was trash she had a bottle of crown
in her hand when she got here
she refused to eat anything she refused
to slow down she was drinking it
straight
i was like what is wrong with you never
hooked up with her before never anything
with her before so i wasn't too sure who
she even was
as a person to be honest with you that
being said
we were talking next thing i know her
hand is down my pants
i told her to stop i was completely
sober she was completely drunk she
couldn't hardly say her own name
um after arguing with me about why i
refused to sleep with her
she started slapping me hitting me
pushing me turned my camera on on my
phone lucky
luckily long enough to catch a majority
of it and her saying that she was gonna
tell the cops and i ripped her
when the cops came they put me in
handcuffs until i was able to show them
the video
of what really happened
what'd you think of that interesting
um do you think that like
girls when it comes to like sexual
assault and like rape accusations that a
girl can just go to the cop and tell
and tell them and get a guy arrested for
rape even if you didn't
most of the time yeah do you think
that's a problem
yeah okay um
do you think that girls take advantage
of guys sometimes they can
yeah have you seen that even like at 14
because you know i do your friends stay
at 14. now
yeah i am sick and tired
all my life you think any one of my
classes dated each other
are you you're a freshman aren't you
yeah i don't know in high school people
started to date
different but this is middle school i
said you're a freshman
i know but it was middle school okay
yeah that's true
of women ruining good men i see all
these women
sitting here crying about how she men
are but nobody's talking about how
y'all are men are not here to provide us
with a golden life on a silver platter
men are not here to be controlled by us
or to cater to our
every need men are not here to pick up
the slack for lazy women
i'm so sick and tired of seeing these
women get in relationship with men
and control every aspect of their life
or try to change him you all knew who
that man was when you started dating him
you need to accept him for who he is or
not date him at all
i am just so tired of y'all ruining
these good men
for the rest of us true or false
most of the time true i think a lot of
girls try to change guys when they date
them
what are you what are you showing me
she's pulling something up on her phone
oh anyway
she showed me an example listen
if you have to wait until you get paid
to
buy me something give me money send me
somewhere on vacation while you work
um if you're going to hit me with the
babe go ahead and pay it and i'll pay
you next week when i get paid
yeah listen my advice to you is to stay
single and save your money
you cannot afford to be in no
relationship especially with a woman
like me
do you think that's common because i
before the internet i've never really
met girls that were this much of gold
diggers but i see it so much online
yeah it happens a lot have you seen it
in real life or just on the internet
only on the internet because i don't go
outside okay
why am i a [ __ ]
why am i put a finger down
hoe edition put a finger down if your
body count is over
three put a finger down if you've
already sent naughty pics
put a finger down if you've made out in
the bathroom
put a finger down if you're flirting
with a guy during quarantine that you
will know that you will never see
like ever put a finger down do you have
boys that you like talk to
yet like what kind of talk too
like with the intention of like they
want to date you like they like you
you have any boys that like you no
you're so pretty though
i mean like sometimes i wish you brushed
your hair but
wait here you're young though you're
young
okay down if you've kissed more than
five people
put a finger down if you've lied about
you had your first kiss yet
no oh you're so cute virginity
put a finger down if you've hooked up
with someone more than three years older
than you
put a finger down if you've had a friend
with benefits
and lastly put a finger down if you've
talked to three or more guys at once
how many girl guys do you think the
average girl talks to at a time
too many more more or less than five
at least three okay
gabrielle calls them her hoes oh dear
when everyone warned you that he was a
player but you thought you could be the
one to change him and end up getting
played
i don't get it oh god
can you do that can you cry on demand no
i can't either
i wish i could i could probably try but
i don't feel like it
i cry a lot just in general but okay i
want to tell you
yeah sorry about my boobs so my boobs
are fake
they're fake but they're anatomical
implants and nine times out of ten men
cannot tell the difference
had them for 10 years and i still have
to reveal to men that they're fake
props to my doctor but anyways the point
is i was dating this guy and we had been
together for about
six months we were having a little chit
chat about our non-negotiables in a
relationship and he looks at me and he
says
i would never date a woman with fake
boobs i'm into natural women
and i look at him and go you realize my
boobs are fake right
and then he says no they're not no i
would know
and i say i'm pretty sure between the
two of us i would know
and then he just shrugs like oh well i
guess i like fake boobs then
and it's so weird because like no one
accused me of lying to him
told me i had deceived him into motor
boating fake boobs or that i was less of
a woman for having a man-made part
nobody knew before we slept together
that my boobs are fake but nobody cared
and in case you missed the point trans
women are women
do you think trans women are women yeah
really
yeah oh i don't
because what do you think what's your
definition of a woman
that's a hard thing to answer
see like for me when i say a woman i
mean a biological woman
so like it's an x and a y chromosome so
like that can't be someone that's trans
and like the ability to have a kid
children are loud and annoying let's get
rid of them also my sister your child
exactly you thought it would be a good
idea to take
shot
but my mom did not like the idea
omg this bee is crazy
i look up to her she takes the shots
with us
such a role model she really said
goodnight world
why are we hyping her up oh god not that
many
yo my mom really went inside
what's she doing seeking oh gosh
seeking man single aged 22 to 35
actively employed in choir at pool free
ice cream and potential girlfriend
golf course
most women would get married faster if
they just hold
back don't give him sex don't move in
with him
don't cook and clean don't do anything
that is wifey duty
if he's only giving you girlfriend
budget you think that's true or false
interesting
[Music]
foreign people can always cook so well
hi dan i just moved in next door i'm a
supermodel
i don't care who the irs sends i am not
paying taxes
do you think you should be able to break
up with someone if they gain weight
i mean it's your choice do you think
it's wrong too
it can be it depends on like
i don't know i guess how they gained
weight
yeah i have a hard time saying it's okay
if they have a child like they carry
drugs yeah
like that's like don't break up with
them for that that's just um
but at the same time i don't think it's
okay to date someone and just like
completely let yourself go
oh wait you got a boyfriend oh yeah what
are you doing out here then girl
he trusts me you know where i'm at he
got my location he know what i look like
hey daddy i'm stuck when i get home
talking to my husband about someone at
work
my daughter overhearing mommy was it a
person or a man
realizing i'm a raging feminist
a couple years ago a guy named eugene
came in to see me
eugene was about 46 years old he had
been divorced about seven years
he had a 10 year old child and a 12 year
old child
now eugene had been faithfully paying
child support
to the tune of about 600 bucks a month
for the last
seven years the problem was is that he
had been paying it directly to his
ex-wife
writing her a check every month rarely
missed a payment and if he did
he made it up the next month the problem
was that the court order
that ordered him to pay child support
ordered him to pay
through the state in this case tennessee
and in tennessee you have to pay it
through the child support receipting
unit he hadn't done that he had paid it
directly to her
well he got a letter from the state
saying that he was over
40 000 dollars in arrears and he was
gonna have to pay forty thousand dollars
you want to know what happened we'll
tune on tune in to part two
to see what happened i know i'm ticked
there's a three-minute thing
well this might have been before do you
think that um
like it's like men when they get when
they divorce
um when they get divorced with a woman
they should have to pay
alimony do you know what alimony is like
child support
no so there's child support um so child
support that's like when you give them
money for a kid
alimony is when you give them
money just for being married
no attack i could be kind of a pain
but in real life i'm just a guy who goes
to work and takes care of his kid
my son's mother and i have joint custody
and she is the custodial parent
but a year ago she took off to kentucky
and
left him with me she came back in august
and since that time she's been living in
a boarding house
but she just got kicked out of it and
who knows where she's staying
but she tells me that she's gonna come
get him today and take him to where she
is and i says
the [ __ ] you are you have nothing for
him to wear you have nowhere for him to
sleep
so i called the courthouse and the
courthouse said i'm sorry sir but you
have to send him
to her no matter where she is
no matter where she is she could be in
the middle of a ditch and i have to send
him to her so you know what i said
let her violate me i will be dead before
i send him
to somewhere he isn't safe fathers need
rights too do you think
men are taken advantage of like in the
court system
they can't be did you know in child
um custody cases what percentage do you
think that men
um get the kid
not much guess like if you had to guess
the percentage
i don't know so out of 100
of cases what percent like 10 20 30 40
50. 35. 35
you think the dad gets it's actually
only 10.
i was very awesome yeah so in court like
men really don't have a lot of like
rights
like usually they just give it to the
woman even if she's not a good
mom
can you stop looking like i'm making you
do this that's my
resting face okay um
is there any other thoughts you had
about those not really
okay guys if you enjoy um these
reactions with my little sister let me
know in the comments
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
um it's only like 25
of you that are subscribed so we're i'm
trying to get to 50
subscribers so hit that subscribe button
and i also just turned on membership so
i'm doing
polls um members only polls and i have
members only content
so if you guys want to sign up that is
going to be five dollars a month
and i will talk to you guys next time